[Musik]
dramatisch schlechte zahlen die deutsche
wirtschaft ist im zweiten vierteljahr so
stark eingebrochen wie noch nie
kroner sorgen in schleswig holstein
immer mehr neuinfektionen gefährden den
tourismus und auf dem weg zum mars die
nasa schickt einen neuen hightech
roboter zum roten planeten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
donnerstag norbert lehmann ist auch
wieder dabei für den sport ein stück von
mir heute wichtige zahlen vom
arbeitsmarkt und aus der wirtschaft nun
ist amtlich was schon lange befürchtet
worden war
die korona pandemie hat der deutschen
wirtschaft einen historischen dämpfer
verpasst das bruttoinlandsprodukt ist
zwischen april und juni so stark
gesunken wie noch nie
und zwar um 10,1 prozent gegenüber den
ersten drei monaten des jahres
zum vergleich während der
wirtschaftskrise 2009 ging es um 4,7
prozent runter die zahl der arbeitslosen
steigt wegen der kurzarbeit bislang nur
verhalten zwei millionen 910.000
menschen hatten im juli keinen job das
sind 635.000 mehr als im juli 2009 10
die quote damals lag bei 5,0 prozent
jetzt sind es 63 simon 20 die exporte
geschrumpft die importe auch der private
konsum ist eingebrochen
corona zwingt die wirtschaft in die knie
es ist der heftigste absturz seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg
und deshalb müssen wir gemeinsam in
europa dafür arbeiten dass wir die
pandemie unter kontrolle behalten
wir müssen dafür arbeiten dass wir trotz
weitergehender sicherheitsmaßnahmen
trotz masken pflicht trotz
einschränkungen aufgrund von hygiene
konzepten sicherheitsabständen dass wir
trotzdem im stande sind die wirtschaft
wieder in fahrt zu bringen
bisher hat es die politik geschafft dass
es zuletzt keinen weiteren corona
bedingten anstieg der arbeitslosigkeit
mehr gegeben hat maßgeblich dazu
beigetragen hat die kurzarbeit hier
scheint der höhepunkt überschritten zu
sein
im april gab es noch 6,1 millionen
menschen in kurzarbeit im mai waren es
sogar 6,7 millionen für den juni gibt es
bislang nur eine schätzung die
bundesagentur für arbeit geht von 4,5
millionen aus dennoch ist die angst vor
arbeitslosigkeit in vielen betrieben
präsent auch da wo man sich eigentlich
ein vollbeschäftigung gewöhnt hat
raphaela kern arbeitet seit acht jahren
bei bosch diese woche ist sie auf die
straße gegangen sie fürchtet um ihren
job in bühl in baden württemberg die
stimmung ist gar nicht gut als jeder hat
angst
entweder deshalb gehen muss oder deshalb
vielleicht seinen arbeitsplatz kinder
momentan hat nicht weiter ausführen kann
und die anschließend bis zu
entlassungswellen kommt wird auch davon
abhängen wie sich die konjunktur
entwickelt zwar gibt es im juli sanfte
zeichen einer erholung aber so vieles
ist ungewiss wir sollten uns nicht der
illusion hingeben dass die krise nun
vorbei ist
eine zweite welle
unternehmensinsolvenzen handelskonflikte
das sind alles enorme risiken die die
deutsche wirtschaft wieder zurückwerfen
könnten die folgen der korona krise
dürften das land über jahre beschäftigen
davon geht man an der börse ein
historischer eindruck wie heftig trifft
es die unternehmen ja sehr heftig wenn
die wirtschaftsleistung in noch nie
gekannten ausmaß einbricht dann eben
auch weil zum beispiel der vw konzern
tief in die roten zahlen abgerutscht ist
und heute milliarden-verluste
veröffentlichen musste airbus spricht
heute davon dass in den zurückliegenden
monaten die auslieferungen um fast die
hälfte eingebrochen sind spätestens
jetzt ist klar der lockdown das war als
wenn man bei großen teilen der deutschen
wirtschaft einfach den stecker zieht
nichts ging mehr ein absturz der sehr
viel tiefere spuren hinterlassen hat als
golf kriege oder die große wirtschafts
und finanzkrise vor gut zehn jahren auch
den dax nimmt das heute ganz schön mit
er bricht um fast dreieinhalb prozent
ein
wenn man an einem tag wie hat dem
heutigen etwas positives sagen kann dann
dass der tiefpunkt dieser krise bereits
hinter uns liegt der war im april mai
seitdem geht es wieder aufwärts wenn
auch vielen nicht schnell genug
dankeschön frankfurt für diese
einschätzung frank beckmann und wir
gehen direkt weiter nach washington
denn auch in der größten volkswirtschaft
der welt bricht die wirtschaft in
historische maße ein elmar theveßen in
washington was ist der unterschied zu
deutschland
der absturz ist ja eigentlich ähnlich
minus 9,5 prozent im quartal das ist der
größte absturz seit beginn der
aufzeichnungen 1875
anders als in deutschland ist die
amerikanische wirtschaft sehr abhängig
vom inländischen konsum und der ist
durch die pandemie fast komplett zum
erliegen gekommen
es gibt ein paar ausnahmen
beispielsweise der umsatz beim kauf von
autos von wohnmobilen von freizeit
gütern der ist gestiegen in den letzten
monaten dazu haben die amerikaner auch
verrückter weise mehr geld in der tasche
durch die direkten staatlichen hilfen
die sie bekommen haben und das heißt im
umkehrschluss wenn die wirtschaft wieder
komplett öffnen könnte
dann könnte der massive konsum dank des
vielen geldes das zur verfügung steht
eben auch zu einer schnelleren erholung
führen als anderswo aber voraussetzungen
dafür müsste die pandemie eingedämmt
werden das sieht derzeit nicht so aus
das gegenteil ist der fall die zahlen
werden schlimmer und deswegen könnte das
nächste quartal wirtschaftlich
vielleicht noch schlechter werden als
das vergangene
danke noch washington mrt wismars durch
die korona krise ist auch die deutsche
bahn tief in die roten zahlen gefahren
obwohl sich viele wochen lang kaum ein
fahrgast in die waggons verirrte fuhr
ein großteil der züge weiter auch weil
es politisch so gewollt war
heute präsentierte die bahn die rechnung
das größte minus ihre geschichte
allerdings die ausfälle durch corona
sind nicht der einzige grund für die
milliardenverluste hans jürgen papier
mit corona in die verlustzone
noch immer sind die züge halb leer weil
bahnkunden die ansteckungsgefahr
fürchten fahrgast schwund mit folgen die
bahn muss das größte minus ihrer
geschichte verkraften und es ist noch
nicht vorbei
ich glaube auch dass wir diese
finanziellen herausforderung die wir im
ersten halbjahr gesehen haben auch noch
im zweiten halbjahr und auch im laufe
des nächsten jahres noch sehen werden
das macht die situation natürlich auch
noch mal besonders dramatisch nach
zuletzt zumindest mageren gewinnen jetzt
der sturz auf 3,7 milliarden euro
verlust in nur sechs monaten darin
allerdings auch fast anderthalb
milliarden abschreibungen der britischen
nahverkehrstochter arriva und rote
zahlen
im schienengüterverkehr
weil man jetzt alles auf corona schiebt
und schieben kann
deswegen guckt keiner mehr richtig hin
und die bahn hat auch unabhängig von
corona erhebliche probleme und der
eigentümer muss dringend auch auf diese
anderen probleme weiterhin gucken doch
auch corona bedingt wird es noch teurer
werden
in diesem papier der bundesregierung ist
von mindestens zehn milliarden euro
verlust bis 2024 zu lesen als
gegenmaßnahme soll die bahn milliarden
zuschüsse erhalten private güterbahnen
wollen dagegen jetzt beschwerde in
brüssel einlegen die bundesregierung
muss den fairen wettbewerb gewährleisten
das ist eu rechtlich erforderlich und es
kann nicht angehen dass nur der db
schäden aus corona ersetzt werden und
den wettbewerbs bahn also den anderen
bahnunternehmen nicht zumindest ein
gutes hatten die leeren corona züge mit
weniger ein und ausstiegen war die
pünktlichkeit zum höhepunkt der pandemie
so gut wie schon lange nicht mehr
um in der korona krise den konsum
anzukurbeln hat die bundesregierung die
mehrwertsteuer gesenkt das zeigt sich
jetzt an den preisen die sind im juli
gesunken erstmals seit vier jahren
gegenüber dem vorjahr um 0,1 prozent
gegenüber juni sogar um 0,5 prozent das
ermittelte das statistische bundesamt
anhand vorläufiger daten
günstiger wurden kraftstoffe und heizöl
etwas teurer dagegen nahrungsmittel und
wohnungsmieten und jetzt der blick auf
die aktuellen corona zahlen im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 610 menschen mit dem
corona virus neu infiziert gestern waren
es noch 570 sorgen bereitet zurzeit
besonders der kreis dithmarschen in
schleswig holstein
dort gab es binnen einer woche 44
neuinfektionen die meisten davon in der
kreisstadt heide
die region lebt vor allem vom tourismus
über eine halbe million urlauber und 6
millionen tagesgäste zieht es jedes jahr
in die küstenorte im kreis dithmarschen
wie zum beispiel nach büsum einer
hebestreit viele urlauber sind in diesem
jahr auch wegen corona an die nordsee
gekommen statt ins ausland zum fahren im
ferienort bösen blicken sie jetzt voller
sorge auf die im landkreis zunehmenden
infektionszahlen die nähern sich dem
kritischen wert der ganz dithmarschen
zum risikogebiet machen würde
für uns wäre das natürlich eine riesen
katastrophe in büsum sind wir überhaupt
gar nicht betroffen allerdings wenn ein
risikogebiet ausgewiesen wird dann ist
ja der gesamte kreis betroffen wer die
urlauber müssten möglicherweise im
heimatland in quarantäne müssen ein chor
attest vorweisen wir würden einen riesen
stornierungswelle hier haben schon jetzt
schützen sich hier viele vor dem virus
verfolgen genau den anstieg der
infektionen macht mir schon ein bisschen
sorgen weil ich ja am sonntag abreise
und da macht man sich natürlich schon
gedanken mittelpunkt des von
urlaubsheimkehrer ausgelösten corona
ausbruchs ist die kreisstadt heide um
weitere ansteckung zu verhindern wurden
dort jetzt alle öffentlichen
veranstaltungen
verboten und strenge kontakt
beschränkungen verfügt hoteliers im
ferienzentrum büsum begrüßen dass hier
ab samstag machten pflicht gilt
ich habe von vornherein ehrlich gesagt
nicht ganz verstanden warum gerade in
der fußgängerzone an den wochenenden
wenn dann noch die tagesbesucher dazu
kommen und sich dort die massen
durchschieben warum da die masken
pflicht nicht gilt
das hat die gesamten anderen
abstandsregeln eigentlich ad absurdum
geführt sollte dithmarschen trotzdem zum
risikogebiet werden drohen urlaubern zu
hause tests und quarantäne noch eine
info für urlauber die mit dem auto aus
dem ausland zurückkehren sie können sich
ab sofort unter anderem bei der einreise
in bayern testen lassen direkt an der
autobahn wie hier in der nähe des
grenzübergangs der a3 bei passau
auch die tests an den übergängen
kiefersfelden und walserberg sind
freiwillig gratis und rund um die uhr
möglich
ähnliche einrichtungen gibt es seit
heute auch an den hauptbahnhöfen münchen
und nürnberg darf die polizei die korona
gästelisten von restaurants auswerten
der gaststättenverband dehoga fordert
eine klarstellung der 16 bundesländer
nachdem in hamburg hessen rheinland
pfalz und bayern solche gäste daten für
ermittlungen genutzt wurden bayern ist
für eine polizeiliche nutzung in
ausnahmefällen baden württemberg nennt
sie unzulässig die daten sollten
ausschließlich der nachverfolgung von
infektions wegen dienen die pläne die
die us regierung gestern zum
truppenabzug in deutschland vorlegte
sind ein ziemlicher schock für die
betroffenen orte in vilseck und
grafenwöhr in der oberpfalz zum beispiel
sind aktuell mehr als 10.000 soldaten
stationiert us-soldaten was die hälfte
soll abgezogen werden
das wäre ein echter schlag für die
region schließlich arbeiten rund 3000
einheimische für die amerikaner und ihre
partner analog und jutta sonne wald
was soll nur werden muss vilseck diesem
bayerischen ort in der oberpfalz mit
seinen gut 6000 einwohnern seit jahren
leben sie hier von und mit den
amerikanern
und jetzt soll schluss sein ganz
schlecht wie manche mit fußball
amerikaner und so weiter das ist schade
denn das zweite kavallerie regiment der
us-armee ist zentraler wirtschaftsmotor
für die strukturschwache region und
bislang ein job garant für vilseck als
kunde und brötchengeber viele
einheimische arbeiten hier dem militär
zu und warten beispielsweise fahrzeuge
die amerikaner beleben das gesamte dorf
geschehen und die geschäfte hat sich 50
prozent für amerikanische kunden bei uns
lassen viel geld hier
es wäre wirklich ganz ganz schlimm für
uns zudem ist hier im laufe der jahre
etwas entstanden das für die menschen
nicht ersetzbar sein wird freundschaften
dieser kreative verbindung vorhanden
die soldaten fühlen sich hier zu hause
wie sehen sie eigentlich als mit möge
die soldaten und ihre familien so
empfinden es hier auch viele amerikaner
erzählt heute ein pensionierter us
soldat dessen frau noch für das militär
arbeitet ich kann nur sagen alle unsere
freunde wollen hier in deutschland
bleiben es ist ein wunderbarer platz für
uns zum arbeiten und so hoffen die
oberpfälzischen kommunalpolitiker nun
auf eine wahlniederlage donald trumps
und damit auf eine rücknahme der
entscheidung
wichtige entscheidungen des
bundesgerichtshofs heute zum vw diesel
skandal es ging um die fragen wer hat
anspruch auf schadenersatz und wie
bemisst sich die höhe
die richter entschieden käufer eines
manipulierten vw diesel haben keinen
anspruch wenn sie ihr fahrzeug nach
bekanntwerden des abhörskandals im
september 2015 gekauft haben und die
höhe des schadenersatzes hänge von der
jeweiligen nutzung ab heißt wer viel
fährt könnte unter umständen leer
ausgehen
und nochmal in die usa dort spielt
präsident offen mit dem gedanken die
präsidentenwahl im november zu
verschieben in einem tweet wirft die
frage auf ob die wahl vertagt werden
sollte bis die menschen in sicherheit
abstimmen könnten
hintergrund ist dass zum briefwahl für
besonders betrugsanfällig hält deren
anteil dürfte wegen der korona krise
diesmal deutlich zunehmen
jetzt geht's ins all für raumfahrer
stehen die planeten in diesem sommer
günstig vor allem die entfernung zum
roten planeten ist relativ kurz nach den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten und
china starteten vor 5 stunden die
amerikaner ihre nächste mars mission mit
einem typischen rover an bord der auf
dem mars ein fluggerät aussetzen soll so
einen hubschrauber hier in originalgröße
der muss sich in der 100 mal dünneren
mars luft oben halten und soll die
landschaft von dort noch besser erkunden
können als die rover am boden auf der
suche nach zeichen für früheres leben
aus washington berichtet britta jäger
es ist der startschuss für die bisher
ehrgeizigste mars mission der nasa vom
raketenstartplatz cape canaveral hebt
die trägerrakete ab mit dem mars rover
passagieren an bord der antworten
liefern soll auf die entscheidende frage
dieser mission gab es leben auf dem mars
wir wissen dass seine zeit gab in der
der mars zumindest in der theorie
bewohnbar war
wenn wir nun feststellen dass es da
tatsächlich auch leben gab dann ist die
frage welches andere leben ist da
draußen wie untersuchen wir wie
verstehen wir dass das wäre die absolut
größte entdeckung in der geschichte
jahrelang haben die wissenschaftler der
us-raumfahrtbehörde an den bislang
längsten schwersten und technisch
komplexes nova gearbeitet
ausgestattet mit so vielen kameras und
mikrofonen wie noch nie soll er die lage
auf dem roten planeten erkunden
zielgebiet ist ein ehemaliges flussdelta
das möglicherweise einmal in einen see
mündete hier nimmt der roboter proben
die hinweise auf organische moleküle
oder gar mikroorganismen geben könnten
in dem krater befinden sich einige der
ältesten gesteine auf dem mars zwischen
dreieinhalb und vier milliarden jahre
alt und das ist etwa das zeitfenster in
dem sich auch leben auf der erde
entwickelt hat mit der untersuchung
können wir also mehr über die
entwicklung von leben im sonnensystem
erfahren mit einem helikopter will die
nasa außerdem beweisen dass fliegen auf
dem mars möglich ist rund sieben monate
dauert die reise dorthin
dann soll der rover in 480 millionen
kilometern entfernung seine arbeit
beginnen wenn die heikle landung gelingt
die neue mars mission der nasa online
können sie mit reisen und zwar
interaktiv mit dem neuen mars helikopter
in 3d was er kann und wie er
funktioniert aus allen perspektiven in
der zdf- heute und jetzt zum fußball
norbert effekt fifa-chef infantino in
schwierigkeiten hat wurde ein
strafverfahren gegen ihn eröffnet genau
durch die schweiz haben
bundesanwaltschaft der präsident des
weltfußballverbandes ist den an justiz
affäre um den schweizer bundesanwalt
michael lauber verwickelt es geht um
geheimtreffen zwischen laura und
infantino 2016 und 17
der bundesanwalt leitete damals mehrere
korruptionsverfahren im bereich des
weltfußballs frage an unseren fifa
experten markus haben was droht
infantino jetzt ja es wird sehr eng für
gianni infantino auch wenn noch die
unschuldsvermutung gilt sind die
vorwürfe der schweizer behörden doch
gravierend es geht um die anstiftung zum
amtsmissbrauch und begünstigung und
zudem müsste die fifa ethikkommission
zur tat schreiten und zwar sofort laut
fifa regularien heißt es es sollten die
suspendiert werden gegen die ein
strafverfahren läuft so war das auch bei
sepp blatter dem vorgänger von gianni
infantino oder auch michelle platini
und nicht nur diese strafverfahren läuft
gegen ihn von tino auch letzte woche hat
ein schweizer gericht schon geurteilt
dass infantino vorsätzlich gelogen habt
er selbst wäscht seine hände in unschuld
teilte schriftlich mit alles diente nur
der wahrheitsfindung und der
wiederaufarbeitung des guten images der
fifa dass seine leser
danke für diese informationen markus
haben zuschauer in den fußball-stadien
wie soll das gehen die dfl will unter
anderem ein vorübergehendes stehplatz
verbot durchsetzen stößt dabei aber auch
widerspruch etwa von union berlin ihr im
ersten mannschaftstraining leeres
stadion wollen die eisernen in der neuen
saison immer komplett füllen
sofern er viel beachteter planen
durchgewunken wird alle zuschauer
einzulassen die einen nicht mehr als 24
stunden alten negativen caron attest
vorweisen
wir haben nicht aus versehen drei seiten
dieses stadions mit stehplätzen sondern
weil wir glauben und weil wir empfinden
dass das unsere art fußball letztlich
auch ist und es ist unsere pflicht
danach zu suchen wie können wir diese
stehplätze nutzbar machen
argumente gegen das steht platzverbot
nennen die fan organisationen
ich glaube dass man sowohl im stehen als
auch im sitzen abstände einhalten kann
da werden die stehplatz fans aber noch
ganz schön an sich arbeiten müssen
allerdings morgen erwartet uns der
bisher heißeste tag des jahres mehr dazu
hat gleich es endlich claus kleber
begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn empor
journal
wir bedanken uns für ihr interesse
wünschen ihnen noch einen entspannten
abend um seinen chips bis morgen werden
sie mögen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wir erwarten für
morgen den bisher heißesten tag des
jahres
das liegt an einem tief was uns die
heiße luft schickt auf seiner
vorderseite wird diese heiße luft
angesaugt das hoch hier erwärmt die luft
weiter aber sie sehen auch eine
kaltfront ganz weit im westen und die
erreicht uns dann zum samstag und bringt
kräftige gewitter mit
in der kommenden nacht wird es nach
nordosten in kühl werden mit neun bis
zwölf grad deutlich wärmer im südwesten
bei 20 grad und dieser wert wird ihr
erster den frühstunden erreicht es
könnte also kaum ab schauen wir auf den
morgigen tag und da gibt es viel
sonnenschein im süden und im westen nach
nord nach norden hin mehr wolken
allerdings kommt da kaum was runter und
die temperaturen erreichen bis zu 38
grad im südwesten deutschlands 35 grad
im rhein-main-gebiet und bis ins emsland
noch 30 grad
anders sieht es im nordosten aus 22 grad
an der ostsee sonst 25 bis 28 grad
ja und wie gesagt zum wochenende dann
die gewitter von westen her am samstag
erreichen sie uns und in der nacht auf
sonntag wandern sie nach osten bis 36
grad noch einmal heiß
am sonntag dann weitere schauer und
heftige gewitter im süden deutschlands
bis 28 grad und montag ein ganzes
stückchen kühler damit ein schöner abend